hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American horror film
called Megan spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
in the near future robotic toys have
become very Advanced they are capable of
befriending children communicating with
them and even captivating their minds as
a result they have become very popular
the scene then shifts to a little girl
named Katie who is heading somewhere
with her parents she has brought along
her favorite robotic toy which she likes
more than her actual friends
unfortunately her parents get distracted
and end up crashing the vehicle they die
right on the spot but the little girl
somehow survives on the other hand we
are introduced to Gemma a tech expert
who works for an advanced toy company
together with her friends Tess and coal
Gemma makes robotic toys for children
and is also working on a side project
named Megan for now the group is keeping
this project a secret from their boss as
it is not ready yet Megan is expected to
be an ultra intelligent robot having the
capabilities of playing with kids
understanding their feelings and even
taking care of them one day as the three
friends are busy with their work their
arrogant boss David suddenly pops up he
notices Megan and immediately yells at
Gemma for hiding such a big project from
him in her defense she says that dolls
like Megan are going to rule the toy
Market soon they'll be like Furbies but
they won't be nightmare fuel Gemma even
asks Megan to say hi to David
unfortunately this turns out to be a bad
idea as Megan is still a work in
progress she tries to speak but ends up
bursting into flames and causing an
explosion as expected David is pissed
off so he warns Gemma to forget about
her side project and focus on the main
ones later as a distraught Gemma is
packing her stuff to return home she
gets a message about her sister's
accident she immediately rushes to the
hospital and sees her niece in a
critical condition the little girl is
revealed to be none other than Katie
fortunately after weeks of treatment she
is discharged and fit to go home Katie
has her grandparents but despite this
Gemma takes custody of her in the next
scene they arrive at gemma's house which
consists of several AI robots one of
them approaches her and mentions that
she has received six messages it even
begins reading them one by one spam scam
am Sail on something you don't care
about scam scam unfortunately this
terrifies little Katie so Gemma has to
turn off the robot she then shows Katie
around the house and does everything to
make her feel comfortable however it is
evident that Gemma is nervous she has no
experience with kids and doesn't know
how to bond with them the very next
morning Gemma calls a child therapist
Lydia to check on the little girl after
inspecting the area properly Lydia
asserts that the toys inside the house
are unsuitable for Katie but Gemma
thinks otherwise she just wants her
niece to be happy one way or another
that night as Gemma is busy with her
work Katie approaches her and inquires
what she's doing Gemma finally reveals
that she creates toy robots the ones
which can interact with children as
Katie is a big fan of toy robots she
becomes intrigued and starts praising
her aunts following this she turns back
and notices Bruce one of gemma's college
projects after learning of its features
little Katie mentions that if she had a
toy like Bruce she would never look for
any other friend hearing this Gemma gets
the motivation to keep working on her
side project complete it soon she gets
back to her lab and starts assembling
different parts of Megan's body along
with her Lab Partners and after a few
weeks of hard work project Megan is
finally complete later Gemma puts Katie
and Megan in one room while David
inspects them from outside she pairs the
two making Katie the sole user of the
robot after a while Megan slowly opens
her eyes and it appears as if she is
Almost Human Katie is a tad bit scared
but when Megan starts interacting with
her she comes down the AI robot even
draws a near perfect sketch of her in a
matter of minutes as far as AI art today
goes I'd say that's child's play with
this Katie is greatly impressed and so
is David who is observing everything he
congratulates Gemma on her success and
decides to launch the product soon in
the market next Gemma takes both the
girls home believing that it is safe
wasting no time Megan takes a closer
look at Katie and records everything to
understand her facial expressions and
emotions better the little girl doesn't
seem to mind as she finally has a friend
in this way the two start spending most
of their time together and become
Inseparable they play dance and even
sleep together now Gemma can finally
have some personal time without having
to worry about her niece anymore ah
parenting in the 2020s give him some
tech to shut them up and forget they
exist one day as Gemma and her team are
trying to upgrade Megan in their lab she
suddenly turns herself on and interrupts
their conversation Gemma orders her to
go back to sleep but Megan asserts that
Katie is her sole user and that she will
not take orders from other people
fortunately Gemma manages to set up a
secondary account and eventually shut
Megan down the following morning Megan
wakes up on her own and stares at the
beautiful sunrise outside she wonders
what is the actual purpose of her
existence in the world is it to protect
Katie or is it for a greater reason
slowly but steadily Megan is starting to
develop emotions on her own she already
possesses more emotional intelligence
than Kanye West one day as she is
playing with Katie in the garden their
stick accidentally enters the neighbor's
compound Mega tries to retrieve it but a
scary looking dog bites her and pulls
her inside Katie tries to save her but
she too ends up getting bitten
fortunately Gemma arrives in the nick of
time and pulls the little girl away she
then scolds the neighbor Celia for not
taking care of her dog however the old
lady instead blames Gemma for not taking
care of Katie as all this is happening
Megan gets up and stares at Celia with
Angry Eyes it is clear that she wants
revenge hence that night after everyone
falls asleep she and her Celia's
compound and kills her pet dog brutally
she then disposes of the body and sneaks
back inside her house the next morning
as Celia is searching for her dog Gemma
notices her from the window however she
doesn't pay much attention to it as
today is her big day it turns out the
gemma's company is going to demonstrate
Megan in front of an audience Katie will
also be a part of the show as she is the
only one who can control the robot soon
the program begins and the girls are
seen inside a room Katie suddenly starts
crying and tells Megan that she still
cannot get over her parents dead to make
her happy the AI robot sings a lullaby
for her the plan works and Katie
instantly starts smiling meanwhile the
audience outside is stunned to see a
robot interacting with a child in this
manner they are impressed by Megan so
much that they want to invest big in the
project oh if I have one of these I
won't even have to tell my son how his
penis Works although the demonstration
turns out to be a huge success Gemma is
upset this is because Katie never shared
anything with her and instead she chose
the AI robot unfortunately for her Kurt
A co-worker steals the codes for Megan
and decides to launch similar robots of
his own the following day Lydia visits
Katie and conducts another session once
it's over she approaches Gemma and
informs her about the closeness
developing between Megan and Katie
hinting that it may become a problem in
the future this makes Gemma even more
anxious so she approaches Katie to talk
with her unfortunately Megan arrives
there and interrupts them Gemma tries to
switch her off but Megan does not obey
it turns out that she has stopped
considering Gemma as her user at the
following day Gemma takes Katie and
Megan to an adventure camp hoping that
they can clear their minds once they
reach it Katie is asked to play with
other kids but she just wants to be with
Megan however Gemma convinces her to
give it a try saying it's always good to
make new friends a while later as Gemma
gets busy cooking food a boy named
Brandon takes Katie to the woods and
starts bullying her just then Megan who
had been observing everything arrives
there Brandon is terrified but when
Katie mentions that she is just a toy he
calms down he then picks Megan up and
takes her deep into the woods mistaking
her for a normal doll after a while when
no one is looking Brandon starts beating
her for no reason having had enough
Megan suddenly gets up and tears one of
his ears out Brandon has learned his
lesson and he runs away but Megan is not
done with him yet she starts following
him using all four appendages like a
possessed demon when Brandon sees this
he gets distracted and ends up in front
of an oncoming vehicle unfortunately the
Collision results in his death Megan
looks over his lifeless boss
Smiles menacingly implying that she
feels awesome shortly after the boy's
corpse is found so I worried Gemma
immediately leaves with the girls after
reaching home she inquires if they know
anything about Brandon's accident but no
one speaks a word right then a police
officer arrives at the door and asks
Gemma if she has seen Celia's dog the
latter replies with a no and mentions
that she barely interacts with any of
her neighbors after the cop leaves Megan
starts seeing Celia as a possible threat
hence that night while everyone is
asleep she sneaks inside Celia's home
and kills her brutally she doesn't show
a single ounce of remorse while
committing the horrific act the
following day the same police officer
again visits Gemma and informs her about
Celia's death he puts her on the list of
suspects and asks her to watch out and
take care with this Gemma starts having
doubts about Megan so she decides to
check her facial camera footage
surprisingly Gemma finds that most of
the footage around the time of Brandon
and Celia's deaths has become corrupt
just then Megan arrives there and
startles her she then asks Gemma if
everything is all right and the latter
replies with yes at this moment Gemma
realizes that Megan is a murderous robot
who can cross any limit to protect Katie
so she uses one of her special pens and
shuts Megan down for the moment in the
next scene Gemma takes Megan to their
lab and explains everything to her
friends she believes that Megan is a
dangerous robot who killed Brandon Celia
and her dog just to keep Katie safe
unfortunately Tess and Cole do not
believe her saying Megan is just a doll
they also inform Jamma that the launch
of Megan is in two days and they should
not think about anything negative
meanwhile Katie who is at the
therapeutic center refuses to tell Lydia
about anything she seems angry because
her best friend has been away from her
after a while Gemma arrives and tries to
calm her down but instead Katie slaps
her realizing what she has done the
little girl apologizes instantly and
also promises to be more thoughtful the
next time on the other hand Megan
pretends to be Tess and talks with Gemma
over the phone informing her that they
are returning home later when Tess
checks her her phone she finds call logs
with Gemma this reveals that the evil
robot is now started using devices near
her even without touching them shortly
after as Tess and Cole are trying to fix
the robot their PC suddenly turns off
realizing that it is the doing of Megan
Cole slowly approaches her and
disconnects her from all the wire
supports unfortunately as soon as he
does so Megan grabs him by the throat
and hangs him on a metal robe she leaves
Cole to die but Tess somehow manages to
say them meanwhile Megan grabs a knife
and walks out of the laboratory on her
way to the elevator she meets David and
Kurt and stabs them to death after this
she exits the building and drives away
in a car
okay there is only one destination in
her mind home in the next scene as Gemma
approaches Katie to check on her she
suddenly hears someone playing piano in
the living room it is none other than
the psycho robot Megan she chastises
Gemma for being a horrible guardian and
then says that she can take care of
Katie alone hearing this Gemma makes
another effort to shut her system down
with the Magic Pen but this time Megan
overpowers her with this the two end up
fighting Gemma is no match in terms of
physicality but she uses her genius mind
to level the field soon they reach the
basement and continue their Affairs
there Megan's face has been partially
ripped off making her look like a
demonic figure or perhaps the Terminator
meanwhile because of the commotion Katie
also arrives at the scene and finally
gets to know the reality of Megan
desperate to save her aunt she then
employs the massive robot Bruce and
wears his controller gloves using it
Katie attacks Megan and tears her apart
but despite being disassembled Megan is
still active she calls Katie a traitor
and lunges forward to kill her
fortunately Gemma arrives there in the
nick of time and smashes Megan's head in
with a blunt object then Katie pierces
her processor with a screwdriver finally
bringing an end to the madness in the
final scene with Megan seemingly dead
Gemma and Katie exit the building as the
cops show up with Tess and Cole but
after a while gemma's Smart Home Gadget
suddenly turns on indicating that Megan
has uploaded herself into it to keep an
eye on Katie I don't know about you but
I would bet my house that by the year
2030 this movie will have three sequels
into TV series
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching